i'm going to describe a type of logic
programming called axiomatic language
axiomatic language has four main goals
the first is intended as a pure
specification language
you tell the computer what to do without
telling it how to do it
but this means you need a really smart
implementation
that can understand the user's
specification
and generate an efficient program and
many would
say that that is wishful thinking
second goal we want the language to be
minimal
programming languages can be big and
complex with lots of built-in features
or they can be small and you add
features by writing them
in the language and providing them in a
library
axiomatic language follows that second
philosophy to the extreme
nothing is built in that can be defined
this means arithmetic
is not built in because it can be
logically defined
now we assume that a smart translator
that can
understand the user specifications we'll
be able to recognize the definitions of
arithmetic
and map them to the machine hardware
operations so there should be no
efficiency penalty now the third goal
is based on the observation that
probably everyone in this room
has a different view of what they want
in a programming language
so if you're going to have a single
ideal language it needs to have the
property of a metal language
a language in which you can define
arbitrary language features
and paradigms which can then be used for
software specification
without leaving the original language
such a language would effectively
subsume other languages
and finally we want the language to be
beautiful
in the sense that lisp is beautiful
axibac language is based on the idea
that the external behavior
of a function or program even an
interactive program
can be specified by a static infinite
set of symbolic expressions
that enumerate all possible inputs
or sequences of inputs along with the
corresponding outputs
for example if you want to concatenate
or specify the concatenation
function you could use expressions such
as this
where you have your two sequence
arguments and
your concatenated result so this is what
that
enumeration might look like initially we
give
the case of two empty sequences and as
empty result and eventually in our
enumeration we'll
get to this particular example of two
these two non-empty sequences and the
concatenated result
so my argument is that that infinite set
of symbolic expressions represents a
specification of the concatenation
function
now suppose you want to specify a
program that
reads an input file and writes an output
file
well that could be specified by
expressions of this form
where input and output are
symbolic representations of the files
so let's say we want to specify a
sorting program that reads an input text
file
and writes the lines of text sorted
that can be specified by this
enumeration
we first have the empty input text file
and the output file is also empty
and eventually in our enumeration we
have this particular three line input
file
and we give the corresponding sorted
output file
now in a moment you'll see that these
character strings
are syntactic representations of
abstract symbolic expressions which are
interpreted to be lines of text
and my argument is that this
this infinite set of expressions
specifies a sorting program and it does
it without giving a sorting algorithm
but what about an interactive program
how can a static
set of expressions define an interactive
program
well here we have express a form of
expressions
where outs is
a symbolic representation of zero more
lines typed by the program
and n is represents a single line typed
by the user
so this expression gives us a particular
execution history
of this program and if you have an
infinite set of these expressions
for all possible execution histories
based on all possible
inputs that the user might type at any
given point
then that set of expressions can be
considered a specification
of this inter interactive program
for example you might want to specify a
program that
reads simple arithmetic expressions and
writes out the result well that could be
done by an enumeration of expressions
where one particular
expression in the numeration looks like
this
the program writes out an introductory
statement
then the user gives an arithmetic
expression program gives a result
user gives another arithmetic expression
program gives the result
finally the user gives a blank line
which tells the program to halt
and the program writes out a final
statement so you would have an infinite
set of these expressions for all
possible inputs that the user might
enter including erroneous expressions
and my claim is that this infinite set
the static
infinite set of expressions is
a specification of this interactive
program
so if you accept that premise that
programs can be defined by a set of
expressions
then all we need from our specification
language is that it be a
formal system for defining these
symbolic these sets
symbolic expressions of sets
or sets of symbolic expressions the next
few slides give the complete semantics
of axiomatic language
in axiomatic language a finite set of
axioms generates a usually infinite set
of valid expressions
an expression can be defined as
or is defined as an atom a primitive
indivisible element
or an expression variable or a sequence
of zero more expressions and string
variables
syntactically atoms are represented by
symbols that begin with the backlog
character
so the symbols you've seen earlier are
not atoms
as you'll see in a minute expression and
string variables
begin with percent and dollar sign
respectively
and sequences have lisp syntax
a string of zero more expressions and
string variables
separated by blanks and enclosed in
parentheses
an axiom consists of a conclusion
expression and zero or more conditioned
expressions
and we use prolog like syntax here where
the conclusion expression
comes first followed by the condition
expressions
which can be spread out over multiple
lines
and comments begin with an exclamation
point
axioms generate axiom instances by the
substitution of values
for the expression and string variables
an expression variable can be replaced
by an arbitrary expression
the same value replacing the same
variable throughout the axiom
a string variable can be replaced by a
string of zero
more expressions and string variables
so here we have an example axiom it has
two expression variables percent x and
percent y
and then this string variable dollar
and we're going to replace the
expression variable percent x
with the atom back quote x and we do
that there
and here we replace the expression
variable percent y
with the empty sequence here
and the string variable dollar gets
replaced by the
two elements sequence or two element
string consisting of
the atom back quote u and the expression
variable percent
and we do that here as well as here
so that is the variable substitution
mechanism
of axiomatic language
axiom instances generate valid
expressions
by the simple rule that if all the
conditions of an axiom instance
are valid expressions occlusion is a
valid expression
and by default the conclusion of an
unconditional axiom instance that is one
without conditions
that conclusion is immediately a valid
expression
so here is an example axiom set
consisting of these two axioms
and here are instances of those axioms
the first axiom has no variables so it
just has itself
as an instance the second axiom has
these two variables
so it has all sorts of instances but
they're just certain specific instances
that are
of interest here this one this one and
that pattern continues
so these instances generate these valid
expressions
the first instance has no conditions so
its conclusion
is a valid expression and then that
valid expression matches
the condition of this instance so this
conclusion is a valid expression
and now that valid expression matches
the condition of
this instance so its conclusion is a
valid expression
and that pattern continues indefinitely
so that is the
inference mechanism of axiomatic
language
and that is the complete semantics of
axiomatic language
so here are some simple examples of
natural numbers and their addition
where the natural numbers are
represented in successor notation
these two axioms define our set of
natural numbers
and the first axiom can be read as
saying zero
is the natural number the next one says
next axiom says that if something is a
natural number
then the successor of that something is
a natural number
and together these two axioms generate
these valid expressions
the first one says that zero is a
natural number the next one says the
successor of zero or one is the natural
number
the next one says the successor of the
successor of 0 or 2 is a natural number
and here we have two axioms for natural
number addition
the first can be read as saying that if
something is a natural number then that
something
plus zero gives you that something
the second one says that if argument one
plus argument two gives argument three
then argument one plus the successor of
argument two gives the successor of
argument 3.
and these two axioms plus our natural
number axioms
generate these addition valid
expressions
which enumerate the addition
function for all possible pairs of
natural numbers
now the expressiveness of axiomatic
language can be enhanced
by adding these syntax extensions
a single character in single quotes is
equivalent to writing this expression
which gives the character code using
this
sequence of bit atoms
a character string in single quotes
within a sequence
is equivalent to writing those
characters separately in that sequence
a character string in double quotes is
syntactic shorthand for
the sequence of those characters and
finally
a symbol that does not begin with one of
the special characters you've seen so
far
is syntactic shorthand for this
expression where you have this
special atom that's represented just by
the backlog character
and you have the symbol as a character
string and this is useful
for decimal number representation which
is not built in
here are some more examples of functions
on sequences
the concatenation function we saw
earlier is defined by this
unconditional axiom and these two
you'll notice these two string variables
capture the contents
of the argument sequences and they're
written
when you write them together in the
result sequence to effectively
concatenate those contents together
so this axiom generates valid
expressions such as this
here we have an axiom which defines the
membership
relation and that says that the
first argument expression
is a member of the second argument
sequence
and it generates a valid expression such
as this
finally we have these two axioms that
define the reverse
predicate or reverse relation which says
that the first argument is the reverse
of the second argument
so here are the complete set of axioms
for our sorting program
we gave earlier we need an ordering
relation on
character strings and we define that
first by defining a relation
on expressions that can be distinguished
by bit atoms
we need an ordering relation on the bid
atoms
and then we need lexicographic ordering
on
sequences and then we need a less than
or equal to relation
defined from our less than relation and
finally we define this
ordered predicate which says that the
elements of its argument sequence are
ordered
now we need a permutation relation which
says that argument one is a permutation
of argument two
and then we have these definitions of
our
of set of characters and character
strings we first define the set of bit
atoms
then the set of bit sequences
and then we define our set of characters
and we make use of this equal length
relation which says that the two
argument sequences
are of equal length and finally we
define
our see define sequences of characters
as character strings and you may notice
that the relation between
bits and bit sequences is the same as
the relation between
characters and characters strings or
character sequences
and we could define a higher order form
in fact i did on the website
that generalizes that pattern and then
you could let these definitions
be instances of that pattern
now we need us to define the set of text
files
which are sequences of character strings
so we could use that that
higher order pattern here as well
finally the sorting function can be
specified as a permutation
that is ordered and that's a nice
specification
that does not involve an algorithm
and then finally we define our program
expressions by specifying that the input
file
is a text file and that the output
is sorted now the calculator program
is more involved and it's defined on the
website
in particular the handling of invalid
expressions
is tricky and i gave several options for
that
now the mental language claim
for aximatic language is that it has the
flexibility
to define the semantics and approximate
syntax
of other languages here you have a
single unconditional axiom
that looks like code in a procedural
programming language
now on the website there are axioms
that define this procedural language so
in combination
they define the function that is being
they generate valid expressions for the
function that is being defined here
such as this one that says the fact that
the factorial of 3
is 6. and the point of this is to show
that this
minimal logic programming language
has the capability of defining a
completely different
language paradigm which can then be used
as a tool for software specification
without leaving the language
and on the website there's there's some
examples of
evaluating nested lisp like expressions
so some final comments i think the
examples show that
specifications can be smaller
and more readable than algorithmic code
and definitions should be
more reusable than code that's
constrained by efficiency
axomatic language has a great higher
order capability in
in extracting common pattern patterns
and
generalizing definitions so the result
should be greater programmer
productivity
the l axiomatic language can be
considered one of those tiny
turing complete formal systems but it
retains
human readability expressiveness and
extensibility
the ambitious metal language claim
is that axiomatic language can
incorporate the specification
capabilities of other languages
and thus subsume other languages
in a sense it's the ultimate in
customization
the programmer can customize the
language to suit his or her taste
and you can customize the language for
the problem
specification by enumeration allows us
to specify
external behavior without
defining internal operation and it
avoids the awkwardness
of input output in declarative languages
the extreme simplicity and purity of
axiomatic language
makes it well suited to proof such as
unfold full proofs
and this would be used to guarantee the
correctness
of your generated efficient program
and with respect to the spec input
specifications
but you still need to get your
specifications right but proof may be
able to help you there too because
it may be possible to prove assertions
about your specifications
that such as proving that a security
property is satisfied
and this could be more powerful than
just testing
so there's a potential for improved
software reliability now the fly in the
ointment
is the extreme challenge of
automatically transforming
specifications to efficient programs
and when you mention that to people
often they chuckle
i think there is a consensus that that
problem is not solvable
that programming inherently involves
telling a computer how to do
something this can be considered a form
of the old automatic programming problem
but in this case the problem is more
focused you're not trying to understand
natural language requirements
instead you're trying to recognize
patterns and
meaning in a formal language
now you can make an argument that no
finite amount of knowledge
can successfully transform all possible
specifications
that the user might write but my hunch
is that a manageable amount of knowledge
may be able to transform
straightforward specifications for
most typical programs
so in this day of driverless cars and a
computer that can play jeopardy
i think this problem is doable and worth
attacking
thank you
[Applause]